protests have broken out in the u.s
state of minnesota
after police fatally shot a young black
man
relatives have identified him as
20-year-old dante wright
the state governor says he's closely
monitoring the situation at a time where
tensions there are already at an
all-time high
the incident comes as the trial of white
minneapolis
police officer derek chovan charged with
killing george floyd last year
is still underway protesters versus
police
in the suburbs of minneapolis tear gas
and rubber bullets
fired at an agitated crowd an
all-too-familiar scene by now
hundreds of demonstrators surrounded the
police station in the town of brooklyn
center
after reports of another black man shot
to death
dante wright died during what should
have been a routine traffic stop
wright's mother said her son called her
when he was pulled over
he called me at about 1 40 that he was
getting pulled over by the police
and i said well why or did you get
pulled over he said he had they pulled
him over because he had air fresheners
hanging from the rear mirror
he was
[Music]
the killing came as tensions were
already high with the trial of white
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
charged with killing george floyd last
year
we're not going to keep taking police
killing black people for no reason
traffic stops
you know mental health problems so this
is just the way that we've learned to
stand in solidarity and show that we're
not gonna you know we're standing for a
cause
who knows if there's gonna be a
difference in this world who knows if
it's gonna be the last time that we all
come together in something like this
the town's mayor called the shooting
tragic and minnesota's governor
said he was mourning another life of a
black man taken by law enforcement
meanwhile the national guard has moved
into place
and a curfew is in effect
you